mmm gonna do quick two quick examples
with you just to make sure you're on the
right page and then I'm going to give
you my final proper rigorous explanation
for why on earth his absolute value
signs appear in our mystery integral
okay so these first year Erica you guys
can help me with it's not too dramatic
when you have a look at it integral like
this when you see this fraction one of
the places your brain should now go is
is this in the form F dash on F right
because if it is then I know how to
integrate it the integral of F dash on F
is the numerator the derivative of the
Dominator if it's that you get the log
of whatever that function is okay so
we're searching for we've got a new
family of functions that we now know how
to integrate if the top is a derivative
the bottom we're good
but sometimes the top is not quite the
derivative of the bottom you sort of
have to twist and turn it a little bit
in this case what is the derivative of
the denominator negative to the top is
not negative two but I can make it
negative two if I introduce the constant
at the front okay watch what happens I'm
going to go ahead and make it what I
want it to be negative two but in order
to compensate for that I need to
multiply by something that turns this
five into the negative two or turns the
negative two into the five same deal
right so what would I need well there's
a minus sign that I introduced so I'm
going to put a minus sign at the front
to balance them we know they'll cancel
yeah how do I turn this into that watch
out be careful we can test this in a
second I'm going to put five over two I
can quickly check it right if I put two
over five I'd get 4/5 but I don't want
4/5 this is where I came from
right so you can quickly visually check
oh yeah I come back to where I started
this is a legitimate equal sign okay and
now I'm ready to go that integrand this
guy here is now f dash on F do you see
it so the minus five over two is there
at the front where it always was log of
what the absolute value of three sorry
that's too long uh-hum three minus 2x
it's indefinite so let's see happy times
okay just for the sake of it because I
know it's easy to confuse let's just do
one more okay in this case it's not f
dash on F but I can make a slight
adjustment to make it f dash enough what
am I gonna have to do what what do I
want the numerator to be I want the
numerator to be 6x so that's not hard to
deal with I'll make it 6x but I will
adjust in order to actually restore it
to what it was so I've got to have a 1
over 6 out the front are you happy with
that so the 1 out of 6 stays there I've
now got the log function since this is f
dash on f don't forget the absolute
value signs happy times so we've got
just enough time actually a little bit
more to really give you a proper
explanation for this and it's not as
hard as you might think
okay I'm gonna call you back to one of
those first statements we made the top
of today which is that the derivative of
the log function is 1 over X with a
restriction what was the restriction one
more time
X is grand zero okay now I can make an
interval statement out of this I just
need to retain that inequality right so
the integral of 1 over X DX is equal to
log X provided it's just for the
positive part is that ok do you see how
I've tried to fix up like just think
about one part of it
oops just think about one part of it
that part does become log X do you see
which part we're dealing with right I
know what a hyperbola looks like but I'm
only thinking about this guy is that all
right and the integral for this sure
enough they share the same domain thumbs
up okay now I'm gonna do something a
little unusual that maybe you wouldn't
expect I'm now going to try this again
but with a slightly different function
log of negative x
hmm log of negative x is gonna require
chain rule right I'm gonna get F Dash on
F on time what's F - in this case it's
negative one humor me what F minus X
that guy now before you start canceling
because it's so obviously you're about
to cancel there is a domain restriction
on this just like there was a domain
restriction on this when we get this
from where did that like what part of my
brain did that come from
it came from where I know this guy goes
and it goes that way to the right yes
now think about this guy what effect
does it have to slap a minus sign in
front of the X you don't get that side
you get the horizontally reflected other
side you get this that's log of negative
X so I have a different restriction on
this different derivative does that make
sense it's not X is greater than zero
its X is less than zero is that okay now
I'll simplify and I get 1 over X with
the restriction which is somewhat
confusing because that's the same
derivative that I got here but for a
different domain does that make sense so
you can differentiate two different
functions and end up with the same
derivative differentiate two different
functions this guy and this guy and you
end up with the same derivative this guy
okay so what I want to try and do is
combine this into one statement okay
here's how I'm going to do it oops I
need one more thing to round this out
let's make the integral statement that
goes with this guy I've got a new
restriction I'm thinking about what am i
integrating 1 over X
where did this go where did this son
come from I should say log of negative X
plus C and this makes sense because look
over on this left-hand side you get the
left-hand integral is that okay
so it's a bit weird your brain is gonna
have to do some mental black backflip to
keep this all together okay but this is
the key now I'm going to combine it all
into one statement okay I'm gonna start
with the integral of 1 over X DX on the
board there are two spots where I've
been written the integral of 1 over X DX
here and here I'll highlight for you and
on the other side of the equations for
both of these have different things so
it's like when you integrate this guy
sometimes you get this and other times
you get this and they very different
answers do you see that sometimes you
get log of X sometimes you get log of
negative X so in order to try and
capture this we have language for this
we call them piecemeal functions you
remember this like don't write this down
you can say hey I have a function and
sometimes it behaves like this right
let's just make it do that for some
domain and other times it does something
completely different for a different
domain well this guy does two different
things in two different domains let's do
them one at a time
when X is positive what does this
integral become have a look just log X
right when X is positive you just get
this guy okay when X is negative you get
a whole different answer right it's like
it's you know the Hulk or something he
just he's a whole different person when
he acts like this okay you get log of
negative x plus C okay
if only I had some kind of notation that
said when you're positive to something
and when you're negative do the opposite
of that wait we do that's exactly what
the absolute value does right do you
remember that this is one of the very
first definitions that I can turn one
last year we said what is the absolute
value of X well it's something that does
two different things depending on where
you are if X is positive then this guy
is just X like the absolute value 5 is
just 5
but when X is negative you do the
opposite of that the absolute value of
negative 3 is the opposite of negative 3
it's 3 okay
so do you need to know this do you want
to understand why these things appear in
this formula you are writing for me it's
the difference between you being a
mathematician or you being a machine if
you just have rules that you just follow
because a piece of paper told you to
then you are a machine you can be a
really good one good for you if that is
your goal that is not my goal
I'm trying to make mathematicians out of
you which means you have to know why the
rules are what they are